in community I see district 13 the
funicular is the most important mode of
transportation Marta arango is glad to
have it trekking up hill on foot would
be too strenuous a trip costs the
equivalent of 25 us cents but many
residents of this district of Midian
still can't afford it a lot has improved
in the past few years but kammula Tracey
remains a deprived area Martha arango is
visiting a school here today her
organization the International Center
for Education and human development
Cindy for short provides teaching
materials and trains teachers Adongo has
been campaigning for better education
for children for more than 30 years the
children take home what they learn here
and that benefits the entire family she
also gets teenagers involved in the work
la comunidad tamiya conciencia the LIBOR
the community has developed an awareness
of how important education is for
children so the teenagers take care of
the younger children it's a lovely
process these girls were themselves
pupils in this school two years ago
since then they've been working with
younger children the school gives them
prospects for the future and they have
fun as well they're also protected
inside these rooms outside it can often
be very different
Steve re lacuna traces embodies this
district's communit racer is controlled
by armed gangs voy de la ley criminals
call the shots here and del barrio sell
your invisible borders you're not
allowed to cross that means the children
have no freedom of movement in their own
neighborhood in builders not win not
when they can't just go to another
school for example Rosa me now sir the
police patrol regularly in an effort to
deter the gangs usually without success
there are no longer any guerrilla
militias as there were ten years ago
when medallion was ruled by the drug
cartel but there are few prospects for
jobs many locals don't even earn the
minimum wage of three hundred dollars a
month the quick money that drug
smuggling brings in is especially
attractive to teenagers police social
workers try to counteract that with
drill and discipline
there are also other places that aim to
attract young people the library for
instance has developed into a cultural
center here children and teenagers can
be on their own a few runs on marta
arango councils mothers they're trained
to be what Cindy calls promoters
community coordinators who then work
with children in their own neighborhoods
Boyan was in buscar we help the women
find the right contacts for their
initiatives but they themselves are the
key players in this process a success
lies in the fact that they don't need us
for long even while we continue to
support their efforts uncle letting him
ha companion this grassroots work is
crucial Cindy supports the women with a
small stipend and where there's no
kindergarten it offers afternoon
childcare the work has given the women
new self confidence my academic
intellectual is my lesson direction
synlait also provides academic degrees
here the social entrepreneur cooperates
with other educational institutions the
end result is a master's degree cinder
uses the income from the cost of the
courses to fund other projects Jordan
comer who we love I'll probably never
really retire theoretically I'm already
a pensioner but there are so many social
challenges in our country and there are
more every day Marta at angle maybe 78
but she has no plans to stop she wants
to make sure that every child in Madine
can attend school